President Biden's snubbing 9 11 Memorial
services today it's the first time a
commander-in-chief has not visited the
attack sites or hosted an event at the
white house instead Biden spending most
of the day traveling on Air Force One
because he apparently couldn't leave
early from a trip to Vietnam
Biden stopping in a military base in
Alaska to remember the tragedy that
killed almost 3 000 Americans
we never forget
each of us each of those precious lives
stolen too soon when evil attacked
crowds are in New York
and I remember standing there the next
day and looking at the building I felt
like I was looking through the gates of
hell I'm just returning from the G
Summit the G20 Summit in India these
trips are essential part of how we're
going to ensure the United States is
flanked by the broadest array of allies
and partners who will stand with us and
deter any threat to our security
to build a world that is safer for all
of our children
the Pentagon Shanksville Pennsylvania
and Manhattan all remembering the 9 11
victims properly with top officials
showing up the White House sent Kamala
to New York City but families say
Biden's no-show is a sad representation
of the state of our country
that's no surprise to me that he's not
coming to uh Ground Zero or any of the
911 sites and quite frankly I prefer he
stay away anyway we will be spared one
of his uh stories of how he can relate
he is now just saying that flippantly
that he doesn't have to come to any of
the sites and commemorate the loss with
the families that's terrible if our
leader is so willing to not show up to
the memorial Services it's showing the
message that Americans have forgotten
and that it's okay to forget but
apparently the White House doesn't think
any of this is a big deal listen to what
they told Peter Ducey
when I asked the White House official
why it is that President Biden was here
and missing the 911 commemorations at
the attack sites the analogy that I was
given is that 22 years after Pearl
Harbor U.S presidents were not still
going to visit Hawaii all right so Judge
Jeanine a lot of people in New York
understand the impact of 9 11. it's it's
a sacred it's a solemn it's a somber day
and the fact that the president is
making excuses and
behaving like that how do you think
that's going over here well it's it's
consistent with his America last uh you
know mentality I mean there this is
unprecedented no president since this
happened uh it it has has not been at
one of the sites whether it's Washington
Shanksville or ground zero and if you're
from New York City especially uh I mean
I was in the city that day I remember
the smoke in the towers I remember you
know my investigators saying we've got
to get home we've got to get back to
Westchester
um this is a very sacred day for so many
people and the president doesn't see it
that way and the sad part about it is
that you know the world is not a safer
place now it's because of Biden now that
the Taliban is back in control in
Afghanistan with all of the weapons that
we left there we've got an open border
now with people coming in that we don't
even know who they are and you can thank
Joe Biden for all of that and then he
doesn't have the dignity or the decency
to show up or even take a pause that
when it is 8 56 in the morning so he
says you know what I was at the G Summit
you were at the G20 Summit here's the
thing you went to Vietnam after and when
the president was asked why didn't you
go to Vietnam before to talk about
climate change uh he said well um Kareem
Jean-Pierre is saying well he is showing
how he feels about 9 11. that's what
you're seeing today it was a non-answer
he could have gone to Vietnam he could
have done Vietnam by Zoom he was talking
about climate change talk about the
carbon emissions that he needed and by
the way this stop now in Alaska give me
a break they all refuel in Alaska for an
hour and a half so what you've got is
the White House who I believe and a lot
of people believe did not want the
president at any of these events because
while the names of those that we've lost
and loved ones and friends that I knew
are being read he's either going to have
you know fall asleep have a snooze Fest
not know which way he's going now would
know which way he's walking and in the
end you heard from the family sir almost
glad he wasn't there talking about
himself
do you agree that the White House was
trying to actively avoid one of these
sites on this day I don't no I don't
have any evidence to that but I do know
that there is a I wouldn't even just say
that they're on the left but certainly I
hear this more for on the Democratic
side that there are people who say
America should move on that we shouldn't
have these four hour long ceremonies
that we need to turn the page on this
and they said this after the 20th
anniversary okay but as you can see
Americans aren't ready for that they
want to have this occasion and actually
what was extremely moving for me today
uh while we showed this on America's
Newsroom or how many young people were
brave enough and courageous enough to
get control of their nerves and stand up
and read several names and then at the
end talk about someone who they might
not have ever known but they wish they
had known an aunt an uncle a grandfather
those were just some of the examples so
I think that America is keeping this
going because when they say never forget
they actually mean it now for the White
House I think that they could have said
we went to Vietnam it's very important
in climate change this whatever but
don't then try to say president stopped
going to Pearl Harbor
just leave it at the fact that if you
think that he had if that work was so
important for him to do in Vietnam great
and the other thing is why why does he
miss every layup this is right yeah
something that you show up as the
president everyone respects you they
thank you for trying to unify the
country even if it is just for a day and
they missed it he's not even able to
execute the ceremonial aspects of the
presidency that's a that's a huge
concern well here's the reason why he's
not going did you see that performance
in India not good yeah he's a cross he's
a cross between you know Jeff Dunham's
doll Walter and the gym coach from
Beavis and Butthead a microphone is a
bigger threat to Biden than terrorism
according to the White House I don't
blame him he's gone he's like a child
imitating a foreign language it sounds
like it's French but it's Babel I blame
I guess our government our education our
media for erasing our unified love for
those who gave their lives saving others
Unity since then has been replaced by
division remember Shanksville it's no
George Floyd but we will never know we
will never know how many black white
asian or brown lives they saved they
gave their lives so others would live we
should be teaching that in class instead
of gender dysphoria but it's not as edgy
or as cool
why bring up George Floyd on 9 11. I'll
make it simple we've changed the
circumstances of Floyd's death was used
to vilify every law enforcement officer
in America it's as if a total of 72 Law
Enforcement Officers didn't die on that
day on 9 11 right
or any other day how many died that just
was erased and it's funny when you
remember that Isis was an idea
they were the JV even though they were
beheading Americans and slaughtered
thousands and then Trump came along and
he beheads the beheaders and now we're
going to jail him we've replaced Isis
with Trump an unruly protests at the
Capitol is now viewed by people in the
media as worse than 9 11. here at Fox
today is 9 11 on CNN and MSNBC it's
Monday
because it's not January 6th
so we have Trump and the military to
thank for not having to think about Isis
anymore which then allows us the freedom
to think about jailing Trump and turning
the military into an equity cult
success brings the downfall of this
country never forget that
that's true 20 years ago terrorism was
the greatest threat to the Homeland and
now Joe Biden says it's global warming
or it's white supremacy well first off
this is a day that that means a lot to
to me and my family and my district I
remember where I was I was in Congress I
was having breakfast in the in the in
the capital my dad phoned me to let me
know that a plane uh a private plane he
believed it struck the capital there was
a confusion in the first plane I said
let me know what else happens I was
sitting at breakfast with the deputy uh
HUD secretary talking about things from
my district he called back so you better
go back to your office the second plane
is attacked I remember getting my staff
out of a young man of Southeast Asian
descent that I was worried knew his
family knew his family well was worried
that he might be mistaken for someone
that many believe at that time it was uh
uh that it was was a middle eastern
attack on the country so I grabbed him
and we got the safety at the United
States Capitol Police I remember how
beautiful the day was how sunny it was
and how surprising it was whomever made
the comment about Pearl Harbor they
should not allow that person to make any
comments again at the white house uh I
don't relate to Stager to any day that
that day that day is above I'm only 53 I
don't have a lot of reference points but
that day
with a turnaround in terms of people
being inspired to serve our country I've
watched Martha McCullum show your show
all the shows earlier we had on Veterans
uh young people who said they were
inspired to serve their country and
fight for their country because of that
day it was the beginning of our shift
and pivot towards being energy
independent we realized that we couldn't
fight a war and at the same time fund
the people who were fighting Us in the
war by buying all of their gasoline and
fossil fuel products we began to
streamline the way our Intel service is
under President Bush how they
communicated we created the Department
of Homeland Security so many things came
out of this day I do hope I was happy to
see the president at a base in Alaska
but they didn't think this one threw
fully the President should have been
here and or D.C and every President
should always be in Washington or New
York on this very solemn day I agree
well said Harold I wanna Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now